[Music]
a lot of changes in life namely getting
a little more philosophical yeah like
I've been more deliberate about my life
for instance I'm not on the internet
anymore like I quit the internet I quit
it for now yeah I mean I hear ago I was
like I'm taking online courses it's my
obsession and I went and gotten all
these courses and I've watched it a
lecture and that's that was it you don't
even seem to care what a lecture was
about hey also I left the thing
backstage I was gonna show you I just
left it I'm really stupid so yeah can
you get something together you have no
one here that works for the show yeah
Frank do you mind getting something go
back I'm sorry it's really awkward
yeah producing your segment you were
like hey go get that huge just like this
he walked faster getting back that
shouldn't make fun of him he's a good
man good man we should end it there
we should just fade to black
yeah people would be so blown away what
was the weirdest ending to a talk show
I've ever seen it's a good man
fade to black okay so I decided I don't
want to be on the internet anymore I
don't like the way it feels anymore
especially on my in my hand the devices
I don't like this thing that I stare
into this thing and it just it makes me
feel upset and I look at things that I
know we're gonna upset me you know I
guess I just liked the hit from going oh
yeah you know like I'll go on my
computer and I'll like Google an image I
don't want to see so then I see a whole
wall of it yeah you know like big dicks
with nails in them
sir you're gonna have to leave the
library anyway so I decided I don't want
and also what the Internet well I have
kids two daughters and I sometimes I'll
be with my daughter and she's talking to
me and we're talking and then bringing
my phone goes bling so I'll just go down
like this and my kids are nice people so
they just wait but I started to realize
a few things one thing I realized in
life is that you can't just go by how a
person reacts you you can't just go like
it's alright with her right because
she's my kid but she dies inside every
time I do this because she thought she
had a real connection you and then
something gling yeah I mean that happens
to you like if you're talking to a
person and then they just go like this
they just they just disappeared
yeah it's a horrible abandonment and
when it's your father just like a hoss
that right honey what she sits it out
she's okay with it and I'm like she
seems alright and then I started to grow
up and realize now I have to think
beyond what the look on her face is
right that she's soldiering on with I
have to think about what I'm doing to
this kid and and I just didn't like this
feeling so I started to put it away I
started to just say I gave my daughter
my phone and I said make a restriction
code and lock me out of the internet
it's supposed to be the other way around
yes rental yeah yeah to keep your kid
off the internet but I had my daughter
give me a code that she has the code I
don't know it and so I can't be on the
internet on my phone and I did it on my
devices and it's been about a month I
haven't looked gold anything I just go
up and walk out to people asking
questions and stuff which is more fun -
yeah but why your daughter and they go
yeah which is fine you lose them that's
right but so so anyway I started reading
books again and I was on vacation with
my daughter and I read Pride and
Prejudice we would just sit there now do
you read Pride and Prejudice that I
never really know I've never read Pride
and Prejudice good Wow I mean there
Craig that crazy you know come on
tell him you like him it's annoying yeah
right you know like 12 years like I
wonder shall he approached me once again
just tell him just blow up hey you're
cute you know but anyway tsofen I did
this for a month and then my daughter
this is why I asked Frank to go get this
is a note that my daughter wrote me
she's 10 years old and right before I
flew out here she wrote me this note
which is messy but she's 10 mm-hmm
not criticizing her I'm just saying yeah
but it could be neither it could be yeah
she says dear daddy I love you very much
[Applause]
um also I am really proud of you for
cutting yourself off from the internet
and reading an awesome book I want you
to know that what you did means a lot to
me and I really enjoy seeing your
pleasure and not constantly being on
devices also thanks for the trip to
Mexico I really needed that so you guys
yeah I think people should know that it
has an impact on your kids if you stop
looking at the stupid internet right
[Applause]
that's right
you